soups can be light and delicate or rich
and gutsy they're versatile practical
and easy to make
and for my ultimate hearty lunch i'm
making one of my childhood favorites
roasted tomato soup
beautiful vine tomatoes the riper the
tomatoes the better the soup
take the core out get your thumb and
place it half a centimetre underneath
the tip of your knife place it in and
then just twist around that's the only
part of the tomato that we're not using
red onion
and garlic
red onion because it's sweeter than a
white onion
slice your onions and your garlic
nice and fine
traditionally be making it in a pot it's
so much better to start it off on top of
the stove searing the tomatoes and the
garlic when it goes in the oven
you actually roast the tomatoes and they
don't stew there's a big difference in
flavor
be quite generous with the olive oil it
makes the soup nice and glossy shiny
salt pepper and then a little teaspoon
of cayenne just gives it that heat but
it's not as fierce as chili
take your tomatoes and just slice them
in half
and then
a little touch of sugar that's gonna
help intensify the sweetness
a little sprinkle
of aged bottled vinegar it gives that
nice dark rich acidity
to the soup
into the oven 20 25 minutes
180. to make my soup even more
irresistible i'm going to make a punchy
sun-dried tomato pesto to drizzle over
the top
now i'm making this in a pestle and
mortar because you feel
so much more in control
and you're not depending on a blade
that's whizzing around at a thousand
miles an hour
next in a dry pan toast off some pine
nuts
toast them the absolute max and then in
smell in there is incredible
parmesan
lightly grate that
this is where it starts to become creamy
extra virgin olive oil
doesn't need salt because the parmesan
is going to season it for you
and just take a couple tablespoons of
the oil that the sun-dried tomatoes are
in really helps to make that stunning
pesto
i can smell those roasted tomatoes want
them out
wow
next pour in a little vegetable stock or
chicken stock so it sits halfway up the
tomatoes
put your spoon through those tomatoes
they break up instantly bring that up to
the bowl let it simmer for three or four
minutes
i want to make it a little bit more
creamy now
cream in
give that a little stir you can keep it
rustic and you get your masher in
and you've got that nice thick
rich
chunky tomato soup
or
get yourself a stick blender
blitzing it like that you delays the
bottom of the pan and you get all those
amazing flavors from the bottom
that's delicious
to make my lunch extra hearty i'm gonna
knock up a deliciously gutsy version of
cheese on toast to go with my tomato
soup
whilst we have it
an absolute classic i'm gonna make a
roux 50 grams of butter three nice
tablespoons of flour and that's all the
roux is basically traditionally you
would use flour butter
and milk
but in welsh rabbit the milk is often
cheekily substituted for a stiff slug of
stout
gives it that strong gutsy flavor
i want it nice and thick make sure those
lumps are out
a nice teaspoon of dijon mustard and
then season it
nice and spicy moisture sauce gives it
that delicious intriguing flavor now
that smells amazing
almost brings tears to your eyes
beautiful
now whilst rabbit wouldn't be a stunning
welsh rabbit without rich mature cheese
soap and a great
montgomery cheddar
goes well with the beer
and drop that in
really important to put this in while
the roux
is still nice and hot because the cheese
melts
now for the bread
i prefer a good rustic country loaf that
will stand up to my hardcore topping
i want that nice crisp
base to my welsh rabbit so toast it both
sides
[Music]
spread that beautiful cheesy berry spicy
mixture
just great
got a blister
and bubble and gratinate
god
a little splash alien perry
and back under the grill for 90 seconds
in one delicious
creamy roasted tomato soup it's coming
back to me all those days i had off
school i used to purposely lie about
feeling ill just to get a bowl of my
mother's tomato soup
how bad was that
but my god it was worth it
oh
now
my welsh rabbit
[Music]
look at those babies that just takes
cheese on toast to another level
wow
roasted creamy tomato soup with a
sun-dried tomato pesto served with the
most amazing delicious welsh rabbit
i feel like ringing in sick
[Music]
all over southeast asia you find people
cooking and eating the huge bowls of
delicious noodle soups it's a very
simple dish but the variations you get
are extraordinary different meats
different fish and even different
dumplings but what i love most about
noodle soup is the fact there's a
complete meal carbs protein and
vegetables in one big bowl of happiness
for my ultimate southeast asian lunch
i'm showing you one of my favorites
spicy clam and noodle soup followed by
sweet morish banana and coconut fritters
for dessert
first up my dessert banana fritters take
your bananas
and to get them really nice and soft
just rub
the banana sip together flour and baking
powder
sugar into the flour
then add coconut for texture and a pinch
of salt
sounds strange in the dessert but it
works brilliantly especially with the
fritters it makes the batter nice and
crisp
start
crushing
and use the back
of the fork and just push it against the
side of the bowl
and then
once you've mixed that through
i'm gonna make that mix now slightly
fragrant with some lime zest
now
the lime
just really elevates the sort of
richness and the denseness of the banana
cover with tim film so it doesn't get a
skin on top sit that in the fridge for
15 minutes
as the banana fritter mixture rests i'm
getting on with my broth for the noodle
and clam soup
fish stock is the base
bring that up to the boil now to take
that broth to another level
in with chopped shallots
fresh ginger add a whole chili seeds and
all i actually quite like it
spicy
adjust
chop once and into the broth
bring up the ball and let it simmer
galangal
it's sort of
almost like a softer version of ginger
slightly milder
you can use galangal paste but i prefer
the fresh stuff
the stems
for the coriander we'll finish the broth
with the
heads and that's what endeared me to the
southeast asian style of cooking
across my travels there was there's no
waste in
lime leaves
for me
one of my favorites incredibly pungent
strong full of flavor very acidic but
gives a really nice aroma to the broth
just tear them
in
now the lemongrass
so the secret here
that's where all the flavor is
right at the very end so you take the
back of the knife and you just bash the
lemongrass
it's all that flavor is going to run out
in seconds that's the base
of the broth done the longer you leave
it the more intense it gets whilst the
broth infuses soak your rice noodles in
boiling water for 10 minutes just enough
time to fry your fritters
the batter now is ready
use a metal spoon to drop the batter to
the bottom of the pan
they hit that oil they puff up that's
why it's important to put your spoon
into the oil so the mixture runs off
and creates this lovely little fritter
and then gently
fry get a slotted spoon and nice and
carefully turn them
the smell
of that lime is extraordinary
fry for two to three minutes
as they start floating
it signifies the fact that they're
cooked
off with a gas and just let them drain
are those beauties
lovely
sprinkling when they're hot with a sugar
actually sticks to them
they're done ready to go
the last job before serving the clams
never be scared of cooking shellfish the
most important rule is if they are
slightly opened
a millimeter discard it make sure
mussels clams are always tight cook the
clams for just three to five minutes or
until they're all open
bring that up to the boil and this is
where we finish the broth
touch of
fish sauce a little sprinkle of sugar
drain your noodles
into the bowl
for added texture
some delicious bean sprouts
get your lime
fresh squeeze and lime juice in
beautiful
literally as the stock comes up to the
boil the clams open automatically
so they cook beautifully
the flavor from inside the clam has
enhanced the broth
smell is incredible
the clams cooked finish with fresh
coriander and serve
there you have
perfect lunch
a delicious spicy clam
noodle with an amazing banana fritter
my spicy clam noodle soup and banana and
coconut fritters made in minutes and
proof you only need to travel as far as
your kitchen to get the taste of
southeast asia
[Music]
spicy mexican soup
it's hearty delicious robust but served
with some tortillas and a wonderful
salsa it's almost like a complete meal
in one
starting with some finely chopped red
onions for my soup
let's get some heat going early these
are chipotle so they're smoky rich they
don't come with any warning signal and
these are seriously hot so be
adventurous
but beware
a nice teaspoon
of toasted cumin
oregano dried
now start frying off spices the heat
you'll see the chilies start swelling up
delicious
garlic
be quite generous on the oil because
that helps to blow out the chili
right now those onions and garlic
are on fire
we're gonna balance the sort of heat
from the chipotle with sugar
turn up the heat
and really start caramelizing that sugar
and the chili
gives off the most amazing
aroma
next fry up a tablespoon of tomato puree
add a can of chopped tomatoes
cook kidney beans
and vegetable or chicken stock to cover
there's something quite exciting about
big and bold flavors because in the
restaurants you have to be somewhat
controlled you can't go crazy
so
cooking these kind of dishes at home
gives me that kind of release chilis
particularly when they're dried continue
to swell and release their heat as
they're cooked so the longer you cook
your dish the hotter it will be
but it's not as powerful it needs to be
yet
and every five six seven eight minutes
that's gonna get stronger
hotter and more delicious
bring that up to the ball and cook that
out for 15 minutes
whilst i allow the chili heat to infuse
i'm going to crack on with quick crunchy
tortilla chips and a fabulously fresh
and spicy tomato salsa known in mexico
as pico de gallo
start by finely dicing three ripe
tomatoes
one or two deceeded fresh jalapeno
peppers
and half a red onion
then chop a good handful of fresh
coriander
add the juice from two limes
salt and pepper
and a drizzle of extra virgin olive oil
for the tortilla chips rub a little
olive oil onto six large shop bought
wheat wraps
sprinkle with smoked paprika and gently
massage in
cut each wrap into triangles and spread
them onto a baking tray
bake for three to four minutes in a
preheated oven 180 degrees until golden
brown and leave to cool
to complete my mexican lunch i need to
finish my deliciously fragrant spicy
soup
the spice is there
it is
absolutely spot on
now for the cooling down process
the mexicans are brilliant at building
layer upon layer of flavor with
delicious chilies and spices but they're
also experts at tempering their dishes
with cooling ingredients like avocado
sour cream and cheese that's why you can
take that amount of chili you'll have a
spoon of richness spice and all of a
sudden avocados
almost like a little fire blanket over
those chillies
to further counter the chili heat
mexicans use a rich tangy crumbly cheese
but i'm sprinkling on lancashire which
is a great british substitute
and last but not least
cooling fresh coriander one delicious
spicy mexican soup
serve that with your tortilla chips and
your pico de gallo salsa
a phenomenal blend of textures and
layers and spice and creaminess big bold
and delicious
you